you've kind of forced our hate and
that's what happens with conservatives
at large no hang on I just want to live
their life and gets it but then when you
start talking when you start yelling at
them about the patriarchy and tell them
to check their privilege they go hold on
a second no I'm gonna have to kick your
question of the day before we get to
DePaul and and what's been happening
with us do you think that campus bias is
a byproduct of ignorance or malice
because we've seen this a lot we talk
about media we talk about the
entertainment should we talk about
higher education what do you think you
think it's a that there's this echo
chamber that sort of created by
happenstance or do you think it's
proactive and anyone out there I would
love to hear your stories if you have
any stories of unfair treatment we see
these a lot in the change my mind
comments section so this stems from
DePaul but it was all over the news last
week had presumably banned the lotto
with crowd her live program for the
nafla now there was some kind of a
paperwork thing and they're gonna be
reviewing interviewing we didn't even
know we were up for it we never ever
requested to perform at DePaul no we had
no clue it came as news like hey did you
realize you were banned from DePaul no
no we were in the running
now we've talked about this quite a bit
um it's about do they apply their
standards equally so campus has the
right to ban people ok campus has a
right it's stupid speech stupid well
it's not necessarily entire like if
Stalin were there no I'm an extreme
example to another point I'm trying to
give them some leeway but you're correct
but the point is do they apply the
standards equally and that's why we want
to get into today specifically with
DePaul and then we're going to give you
a lot of credit um slashed or were you
know the instructions to bring us to
your school I don't think it's what they
think it is no it's it's clear different
program than I think people think it's
not even a luxury it's this your team of
programs their sketches or stand-up it's
it's it's a full multimedia program so
let's go through DePaul let's use it as
an example they of course try to shut
down Milo everyone knew that know where
they were requiring I think the College
Republicans to pay an extra thousand
dollars in security for his event here's
what happened the College Republicans
paid the one thousand dollars and then
the Paul had security and police stand
down anyway to not protect the event and
so students violently storm the stage
and they shut down the event and
promptly banned Milo from ever coming
back they banded notorious Jewish Nazi
Ben Shapiro remember that they banned
Ben Shapiro and then this we dined out
on this for weeks with with sketches
DePaul
all security threatened to have him
arrested when he came on campus roll it
so I might understand that if I take
three steps forward you all the time to
have me arrested if you create a problem
and you will not you know leave the
campus yes always creating the problems
they might have believe you're going to
have me arrested he knows we're gonna
have him arrested he know he's a lawyer
he knows the answer to that question
there's a bedroom pleadingly just please
don't pop me like this please please
don't trouble me up like an old pack of
cigarettes and I love you Ben DePaul
they don't just ban conservative this is
also MIT they try to ban conservative
speech from students Wow so when when
they tried to ban the chalk on campus
down some students were triggered from
pro-trump chalking I don't know how you
ban shock know it just wait for the next
rain falling even laughter a spring rain
maybe most insanely DePaul a Catholic
University okay now it doesn't matter
what your opinions are on abortion they
banned students from posting pro-life
posters a Catholic University they had a
pro-life posters and said unborn lives
matter the president Dennis Holt
Schneider we're an open letter to DePaul
claiming that and I quote the posters
constituted bigotry under the cover of
free speech that quote provokes the
black lives matter movement really if
anything that should read unborn black
lives matter to be statistically
accurate yep exactly
you know the people people in United
States most likely to be aborted unborn
lives matter unborn lives matter is hate
speech it's even controversial speech
even more controversial on the left of
speakers who face no censorship at
places like the problem at how radical
reviews like Ward Churchill who is
famous for argument United States
provoked 9/11 and compared the role of
financial workers at the World Trade
Center to Adolf Eichmann organizing to
Holocaust just as better than flat-tax
Rosel yes exactly
unborn lives matter just as bad as Ward
Churchill so not only did they not ban
him they were the University did ban
students from protesting his talk the
students were even banned from putting
up probe they would have been phoning up
protesting posters this is starting to
be then of course the chalk the ball
also host it again is it applied equally
no he hosted a fundraiser on campus for
radical leftist activists convicted
terrorists freshman
remember her she was convicted in an
Israeli Court for playing a part in two
terrorist bombings one of which killed
two students you would think that that's
bad PR for university who's the fund
raiser for this broad didn't she kill
students maybe but yeah this is the
right kind students students who talk oh
we don't like them anyway so here's
here's they're reviewing it at this is
what happens it creates that that equal
and opposite reaction we never planned
on going to DePaul we never requested it
now if you get a lot of credit outcomes
test or we do have some some dates
coming up at I think SMU somewhere in
Illinois someone Alabama we don't want
to give you the finalized dates because
they might ban us and you can send an
email there at laterals credit.com
Celeste or if you want to bring us to
your campus and work with ya fueling
America's they'll help bring us to your
school so you can see the show live but
this is that equal and opposite reaction
before we never okay we never plan on
going to DePaul now don't we heard how
like I I think I want to know is this a
threat no it's not a threat but if you
don't bring us in to DePaul at this
point we might just have to go on down
there do what change my mind somewhere
on your campus
the pollutes we don't even want to go
who wants to go to DePaul but now you've
kind of forced our hate and that's what
happens with conservatives at large
yelling all right they just want to live
their life and gets it but then when you
start talking like when you start
yelling at them about the patriarchy and
tell them to check their privilege they
go hold on a second no I'm gonna have to
kick your that's what's happening so
louder with greater calm slashed or if
you want to bring the show to your
campus and like we said a lot of people
don't know what it's about it's not just
a QA it's not just as going there and
rabble-rousing it's a full multimedia
show here's actually a promo lot
Oklahoma Celeste or if you wanted at
your school
[Applause]
here we are and Virginia Tech is filled
to the brim I can you believe this shine
live we're gonna catch some we're going
to be back at the end Xu Fei that's easy
I contributed 250 hours of community
service the only problem is that the
community service was mandatory as a
felony plea bargain
[Applause]
you don't need a deep weaponize empathy
you just need to steal it from the left
that will go back to Kevin Spacey scenes
didn't have to reach deeper motivation
he could read erase it but he didn't
reach deeper renovation
you were expecting something else she's
a maternal love well take us in the next
era of mankind just but you know it
people's kind of like oh my god break
off a pool cue demand tryouts only if
both keep stamping her side of the face
people are aggressive people are
attacking you make an example of them
make it sting so badly that the person
watching goes where he really pitched
left that person maybe he knows what
he's talking about the cancer and we're
good assets to make the phone variable
make sure that he could find counseling
wait am i under Derek's go ahead that's
right
[Applause]
hey did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright